[Musica]
ma voi da piccoli ce l'avevate quell
oggetto magico anche semplice che vi
permetteva di volare fuori dalla vostra
cameretta e sognare
il mio era una piccola valigetta russa
all'età di quattro anni aveva un
bauletto rosso quello che pulsanti a
scatto e un oggetto importante per me e
io ogni volta mettevo in scena sempre la
stessa storia
chiudo il mio bauletto claque vado verso
la porta
sognando di prendere un volo e partire
per un'avventura
all'età di nove anni aveva una valigia
un pochino più grande ma sempre rossa
quella con cui come tutti i figli dei
separati mi spostavo tra mamma papà e
nonni che nel mio caso vivevano non
soltanto in città diversa ma anche in
azioni
e mal di pancia tipicità distacco e
l'emozione di vedere un genitore
piuttosto che un altro c'era una cosa
che mi entusiasmava veramente tanto in
quegli spostamenti
il volo finire con un porta documenti al
collo ed essere affidata ad un hostess
di volo mi faceva vivere la magia di un
avventura
è la sola idea di volare
mi dava energia e aumentava in me il
desiderio di scoprire il mondo
con una motivazione così forte non
stupisce che a soli 20 anni indossassi
una divisa quella di alitalia pronta per
spiccare il mio volo
era ancora l'epoca in cui nero destava
fasci l'ammirazione era l'unico mezzo di
connessione di luoghi lontani e io avevo
realizzato il mio sogno il volo
volare appagava a quel desiderio di
scoperta e di avventura che ragioni
siata durante la mia infanzia quando i
protagonisti eravamo io e la mia valigia
rossa
ma
la vista privilegiata sopra i cieli del
mondo
e la conquista delle mie ali della
libertà
non mi hanno messa al riparo dalle
cadute
quella caduta in cui ci si fa anche male
arriva all'improvviso in silenzio senza
che te lo aspetti
la mia mi ha colto alla sprovvista e
stata surreale
un po come quel quadro di salvador dalì
non so se lo conoscete quello con il
nome lunghissimo il sogno del vole
dell'ape intorno alla melograna prima
del risveglio
io l'ho scoperto da poco e mi ci sono
subito ritrovata perché parla del
risveglio di una donna dei suoi sogni
tranquilli
il mio primo risveglio dei sogni
tranquilli è arrivato 27 anni quando
dopo una gravidanza complicata
ho dato la luce il mio secondo figlio
alessandro con quasi tre mesi di
anticipo
rivedo ancora lo sguardo del medico
mentre mi dice
signora le condizioni del bambino sono
molto gravi si prepari al peggio
finisco in un buio insopportabile sento
solo angoscia impotenza vedere mio
figlio così piccino attaccato tutte
quelle macchine e paralizzante e la sola
idea di vivere una vita senza di lui mi
fa desiderare di non esistere più
fino a quando un giorno
improvvisamente
scatta in maine qualcosa che mi
ricollega le mie ali che mi sollevano
dal letto e mi fanno guardare a quell
angoscia in un modo nuovo
una forza che non pensavo di avere
perché effettivamente
forse resta nascosta fino a quando non
serve davvero
una forza che richiede un coraggio
particolare che c'è si trova in fondo al
cuore irrompe all'improvviso riempiendo
tutto di energia vitale che mi ha
rimesso in movimento
immaginiamo una come una formula magica
con questi elementi
coraggio cuore e azione
il mio coraggio di agire l'ho trovato
dopo sette giorni in cui ero paralizzata
a letto dalla paura di perdere al mio
bambino
è scattato un qualche cosa per cui
anziché subire passivamente ho deciso
che avrei impiegato tutte quante le mie
forze
accanto a quel corpicino attaccato a
decine di tubi e sospeso tra la vita e
la morte e che avrei lottato sarah è
stata accanto a lui pronto ad accettare
qualunque cosa fosse accaduta
in quella svolta c'è stata una scelta
consapevole
quella di uscire dalla paralisi del
terrore smettere di sentirmi vittima
degli eventi e diventare protagonista
una scelta
che ha cambiato tutto e che rimessi in
moto l'energia
grazie a coraggio cuore e azione
e da quel momento in poi come per magia
mio figlio è uscito fuori dal coma
un miracolo
oltre i limiti e le aspettative della
medicina
forse ma io sono profondamente cambiata
e quel cambiamento ha spalancato la
porta al capitolo successivo della mia
vita
così
lentamente
ho ripreso il mio volo e dopo quasi
vent'anni di
viaggi avventure intorno al pianeta ho
deciso che era arrivato il momento per
togliere per sempre la divisa e cambiare
rotta la mia vita
fino ad allora credevo di aver vissuto
molte esperienze superato diverse sfide
credevo anche che fosse il momento
giusto per compiere quella scelta vista
anche la tormentata storia di alitalia
e soprattutto anche per dare più
stabilità ai miei figli
e poco dopo aver lasciato il mio lavoro
in un momento di transizione in un
semplice dalla mia vita
è arrivato anche un momento di gioia e
la mia con l'arrivo inaspettato di un
terzo figlio
ma quello che non sapevo
era che quella gioia
era l'attimo prima di un altro violento
risveglio dei sogni tranquilli
in un attimo sono finita in un tunnel
buio fatto di dolore solitudine e
delusione
dolore perché ero diventata il bersaglio
di continue umiliazioni e denigrazioni
che quotidianamente facevano a pezzi la
mia dignità
solitudine perché ho visto persone
prendere le distanze da quello che stavo
vivendo
leggevo nei loro sguardi un pensiero
ricorrente che semplifica tutto e non
vabbè dai se ci sei finita dentro in
questa situazione per la farai cercata
delusione perché ho speso tempo energie
e risorse lacrime per raccontare la
verità
che servita soltanto ad aumentare i
polverosi faldoni che affollano gli
archivi dei tribunali inutilmente
stavo vivendo un lungo incubo
sembrava non finire più
mi sentivo
sola impotente
circondata da periti consulenti quelli
che orbitano intorno alla giustizia come
le iene sulle carcasse mia e di mio
figlio piccolo
uno di quegli incubi non sei mai
capitato di studiare di urlare a
squarciagola ma in modalità muta
uno straziante dove però nessuno sempre
e si accorge di nulla
e io cercavo disperatamente aiuto
ma senza mai trovarlo
nel momento della mia vita in cui mi
sentivo più fragile avevo perso tutto
avevo perso la mia stabilità avevo perso
la mia dipendenza
avevo perso la mia autostima e
soprattutto avevo perso le mie ali
fino a quando mi sono resa conto è in
realtà
l'aiuto lo stavo cercando dalla parte
sbagliata
perché nella mia vita trascorsa sugli
aeroplani
avevo ripetuto centinaia di volte
e in caso di emergenza
in caso di mancanza di ossigeno in
cabina
bisognava prendere una maschera e
tirarla energicamente verso di noi
comprendo naso e bocca e respirare
normalmente
e solo dopo aiutare coloro che hanno
bisogno della nostra assistenza
la svolta è stata proprio in quel
energicamente verso di noi
perché in un'azione energica verso me
stessa in cui ritrovato quella forza
nascosta
che ha dato il via ad una trasformazione
e la prima cosa giusta che ho fatto
mentre viveva in affanno è stata quella
di sviluppare una relazione con la parte
più autentica di me
come una radio dovevo riso utilizzarmi
sui miei reali valori ascoltare i miei
bisogni le mie ambizioni
ed è nella relazione con me stessa che
ho trovato e non soltanto nel prendermi
cura delle mie fragilità e delle mie
paure che ho scoperto in realtà che
proprio quella parte che stavo più
difendendo nel mio cuore in realtà c'era
una via d'uscita e grazie a coraggio
cuore e azione ho ritrovato le mie ali
perché è proprio nel cuore che scoperto
una forza che non avrei mai creduto
possibile quella del perdono
intendiamoci un perdono che non ha nulla
a che vedere con un condono o con un
salvacondotti meritato ma con un dono
che ho fatto
essa è che mi ha permesso di liberarmi
di tutti quei paesi che non mi servivano
più e spiegare le mie ali e delle barbie
oltre
oltre alle prepotenze
oltre alle umiliazioni
oltre alla rabbia per l'ingiustizia
subita oltre
e dopo che ho iniziato a respirare
normalmente
ho potuto aiutare anche coloro che
avevano bisogno della mia esistenza
i miei figli
e incredibile e proprio dal cuore la
parte che più credevo ferita chi abbia
ritrovato quell'energia al propellente
che mi ha lanciato al livello successivo
della mia vita
facendomi arrivare veramente a traguardi
che non avrei mai pensato possibili
e come se avesse dovuto vivere molte
vite in una per poi imparare che in
realtà non ci sono limiti a quello che
possiamo fare e sa dove possiamo
arrivare se non quello che ci mettiamo
noi
l'unico grande limite di cui bisogna
assolutamente disfarci e non sapere che
siamo veramente di che cosa siamo
realmente capaci
il credere di essere
fragili inadeguati o sfortunati è un
grosso inganno e se noi ogni giorno
mettessimo nelle nostre vite
solo un po di coraggio cuore e azione
riusciremo veramente ad arrivare ovunque
con la consapevolezza che siamo noi
protagonisti
e se io oggi
vi regalo il mio bauletto rosso
voi
da domani che cosa è che scegliete di
metterci dentro per spiegare le vostre
di ali
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì